يطفئون ضمائر عليه حر الشمس وحر العطش
مكونات اهليه بمدينه بورسودان بادرت الى
توفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه لمن تاخر
اجلائهم من الاجانب وتقطعت بهم قرب
الميناء ما في فريق
بيته الخيريه
بالنسبه للمطبخ بتاعنا نحن بنقدم وجبات
طول اليوم ثلاثه وجبات في اليوم لمختلف
الناس الموجودين معانا لما بيتم اجلاؤهم
وسط العالقين قرب الميناء يتجولوا فريق
طبي ميداني لتقديم خدماته للمرضى بمختلف
جنسيتهم
ومع استمرار عمليات الاجلاء وتوالي تدفق
الرعايه الاجانب الى بورسودان جهزت مراكز
ايواء داخل الاحياء لاستقبال موجات جديده
من الساعين الى مغادره السودان
هنا عشرات من المتطوعين وقد انهمكو في
اعداد وجبات ستوزع على الاف العالقين قرب
الميناء وداخل الاحياء
بسبب الخوف والفزع الحصر بيناتهم بسبب كان
الرصاص بيدخل في بيوتهم الناس بس استعجلت
فيه وهو الزول بيحفظ سلامته وبيحفظ ابناء
اولاده وبيطلع بنفسه وباهله بكل الموجودين
حوله وبيطلع بيا يعني الحمد لله في
السودان كلها يعني ما مقصرين في كل
الولايات
هنا عماره سكنيه في احد احياء بورسودان
افردها صاحبها لايواء اكثر من عشرين اسره
من جنسيات مختلفه بالمجان فضلا عن التكفل
باطعامهم
لم تتوقف معاناه الفرين من جحيم الحرب
وويلاتها بل ان فصلا جديدا من فصولها لا
يقل ماساويه بدا مع سعي الاف الرعايه
الاجانب الى مغادره السودان اسامه سيدي
احمد الجزيره بورسودان